okay for people who are joining our
livestream this is a another internal
meeting in our infinite series of ones
discussing incremental language features
of open language so let's start off here
with formatting of intervals with
quantities so wow those are difficult
cases okay so the issue is what should
be the standard way of representing yeah
these are difficult cases because let's
look at ones which are a more reasonable
range like these are all pretty big
ranges here well let's take this one
here point zero for this because
interval to be safe rounds one smaller
step invert so whichever all intervals
of zero which outer bound to this small
machine number which is crazy yeah but
this doesn't 25 years well the new
typesetting will allow us to do
something nicer yes right I don't like
that I think it should be a - but I
think this is specific we think this is
specific to quantities right we don't
plan to do this for other uses of enter
vote no you had only suggested and I
fully agree it should only be for
quantities by the way if I use sound
like you're in a cave you might want to
is this better yep you mean as opposed
to having it for all uses of interval
right either all the uses of interval or
you know not doing yeah I mean I don't
see why difference inside of quantity is
it because quantity is already doing
heuristic formatting and it's a case
where you know intervals use generally
can be pretty arbitrary
whereas this use is really for measure
things and they have let's let's discuss
what we're gonna do for interval for
quantities first and then we'll loop
back to whether we can apply the same
reasoning to general intervals okay so I
think in the literature - a long - is
the thing that is uniformly used for
this is that a true statement Michael
they do not know it's definitely used
but they're not sure if it's the
majority even well I've never seen this
well sometimes there is they actually
interval notation with brackets yeah
that's something else and that's much
more mathy yeah I mean this is look if I
say um let's say something like I don't
know I mean if I go to a typical let's
go to okay let's look at I don't know
should we look at experimental
high-energy physics for a minute yep my
god this is the stuff I used to do like
40 years ago exact same type of thing
only the only thing that's changes the
energies okay let's take a look here so
they have okay there's our plus/minus
notation um let's just see whether they
have a range kind of thing here
nothing um oh boy they now have that the
the authors in our footnote um gosh I
can't believe this stuff it's just
exactly the same things that were being
studied before except that it wasn't
even it was um you know is just making
it to a GeV back in my day okay a lot of
plus/minus stuff
I noticed that they're using the
two-digit convention for their plus
minuses which is encouraging I'm just
flipping through the particle data book
and I'm seeing lots of plus minus and
also less than right yeah less than is
something we haven't really covered in
other words things which that's an
interesting format in case is the the
about case where it goes about how do we
handle that we're in the case of about
how do we handle something which where
we know it's less than some value with
this standard thing so far 0 plus minus
something of course if you know that
it's positive yeah then it should be a
symmetric or we can have a special
notation for that well all you believe
we should have a special wrapper for
that case but I think that's not gonna
come up because I admit it gets
different for the case where it's merely
less than well that arguably there might
be something we need to expand to what
is the arithmetic in that case nothing
that has a closed form anymore sir but
we could still have some sort of a
symmetric interval which is zero one
side then yeah what Michael is saying is
if you know the thing well okay if you
know it's positive yes you can
okay the point is with an interval with
an asymmetric plus/minus where the the
asymmetry goes down to zero you're not
hard bounding it above zero exactly
you're just saying the tail you know
there might be a tail wagging below zero
but it just isn't so the question is is
there a formalism that represents the
case where it actually is strictly
bounded above zero this is the truncated
probability distributions but a few so
in around we always have some sort of
extended distribution okay here we are
talking about intervals which is
something different no I I agree I agree
but I'm asking the question in around
ology so to speak that is you know
around should be able to take every
number that's in the particle data book
and represent it nope that definitely
someday don't fall into this okay what
which like which neutrino masses they're
strict in the words we have no idea what
it is we trust everyone we have lower
bounds for things which are you know
masses above right that principle you
can have infinity as the as the you know
you could have an asymmetric interval it
extends to infinity but I didn't
understand your statement about neutrino
masses other than the fact that they're
positive what aspect of them we
currently do not even know in which
scare they live so we cannot give a mean
yeah you're saying there's no plus/minus
there's a color range for the new fuel
range okay so not every many many let's
just think about that how does interval
interact like that range let's say the
neutrino mass is between you know 10 to
the minus 3 electron volts and you know
2 electron volts or something yeah
neutrino mass for that but anyway the I
think to you the Wow is it really that
good abound these days back in my day it
was could be in the MeV range um anyway
but but um um it's so sad all those
particle numbers that I that I actually
knew like you know the mass of the Sigma
is 1 3 8 5 MeV or something those digits
aren't all correct anymore so sad um
okay in any case um let's see the the
but but what is your point so if you
have an interval like this kind of minus
3 to 2 does that play nice with around
numbers or not no what does it do I
would say that we have already a
representation for an interval and then
around is more like simplified
representation for a normal distribution
well I agree but I'm asking you the
question if I say let's imagine that
I've got a decay it's like where decays
into you know some particle that tastes
a neutrino and we're trying to figure
out what's the mass distribution I don't
know of some other thing right but the
mass of the particle is no one as an
around number and but the mass the
neutrino is known as an interval what do
we do if we do or admit Equus both okay
but what how does the arithmetic that
combines them work do we get an interval
out at the end or do we get in a round
number out at the end well
mm yeah we have to make some kind of
decision right I mean if you I mean
arguably if they around I mean okay so
here's a criterion if the around
distribution is much broader than the
interval it's like great there's an
interval it's between 2.07 and 2.08 but
the other thing has is 1 plus or minus
0.3 clearly the interval is smothered by
the around distribution right and
similarly the other way around so I
would argue that what you get out
depends on you know which one is the
dominant source of error by this is nice
form the semantics it's not nice for
programming if you get different heads
out well but so okay but we already know
that there's a way of getting from the
around you just wrap it in an interval
and you get the interval right yeah
similarly presumably when you have an
interval you can wrap it in and around
and it will give the around version of
that interval is that not correct
we could do that we are not doing that
right now but we could I think we should
so I would argue that the right behavior
is you know look at what the dominant
source of error is and return it in that
form um and you know okay but so let's
now go back to this and discuss the
question of how so how we deal with
these intervals so you know clearly we
don't want it I mean you know the kind
of thing we would use is um let's say
what is it called it's called a long
dash or something it's all right Jeremy
do you know what well that doesn't look
right but but you know something that
looks terrible I mean that looks like a
minus sign do we have Jeremy here option
- or shift option - for him - that's the
same thing
okay so one question is do we always
parenthesize an interval I think so I
think this looks terrible I mean I think
that if we're gonna do something like
this oh oh gosh okay question okay good
good question Jeremy um okay so if
they're both negative arguably the the
minus sign should be factored out like
that right if they're both negative if
one of them is negative then it looks
something like this right it's gonna
leave this two plus six now I mean
that's very very very super confusing
that particular form they're arguably
this should be um should say going up to
plus six here that looks terrible right
now but but if we space it out better it
might look better we could insert that
too in between rather than the - do we
really want that much text in there how
much wider it'd be clear for me I think
that confusable with the minus sign
go ahead - like Japanese uses a wavy -
sign and that prevents confusion with
minus signs and I think it's kinda
readable you know it's just wavy it's no
no I've seen those I've seen those I
mean that do we have a Unicode character
that corresponds to that do we know what
that would be yeah I have seen that
actually in Japanese journals
particularly um Michael do you have you
seen those things also I see her I've
seen them okay so let's let's enumerate
the cases that we have okay somebody
have a Unicode version of it Unicode
3:01 see it's called a wave - okay I
wonder whether we have that as a
character that would be a
would be a worthwhile thing to know do
we have backslash bracket wave - doesn't
seem like it so that will be a thing by
the way to get added that would go to
Andre okay
um okay so this is Unicode I never use
this way of doing it 3:01 C is their own
ah
amazing okay so this would be something
like that
then it's pretty funky wavy always seems
to represent approximation rather than a
range right
yeah and the dot dot which I don't like
it all tends to represent a sequence
from here to there which is again a
different thing right okay so let's
let's look at what we might have so we
might have this we might have so the
other thing being proposed
ohtori what do you mean by what's
different to a sequence that there are
intermediate pieces as opposed to turbo
I'm not convinced a a very common form
to input definite integrals in alpha is
from x equals zero dot dot one okay but
I think that that's okay I'm not
convinced by that as being okay so this
one here let's imagine what do we do in
alpha for this what do we do for the I
mean don't we have a that we use to in
in
I think new to your math you can't I
should work okay let's try a new trick
on us yeah we used to oh yeah I have to
admit that looks pretty reasonable I
mean and those are that's a very nasty
case right because that's going from and
it has grey parens around it
well maybe we already solved this
problem
Jeremy any comments no I like this I
think not too wide and it's clear yeah
it looks good
and it's got those parens around the
outside I mean maybe okay if the first
one is one or two times total mean
machine on board then we form a DT so I
think so is there any case in which we
will go in different units here
something like a unit to being with the
number I don't think we have that
possibility do we I mean if you do an
interval from one what's said it
canonicalize is do a single quantity or
something like that yes I know but I
wondered that with a fourth type setting
I mean whether know if one of the
numbers is much smaller than the other
one whether one should be grams and the
other kilo ohms or something I think it
would be pretty confusing for my things
to reflect units that it doesn't
actually have right what are we doing
for negative numbers which way round is
the interval go for negative powers
actually let me let me just look at the
obvious thing if I do - - 2 - 6 I think
it reverses its it's kinda set in
between so it's another one right but so
what would that format like with this -
thing with the - be factored or with the
- be each individual one - 6 2 - 2
probably it has to be minus 6 to minus 2
yeah yeah I think so what's easier to
read fine all right I think we have a
solution to this no objections and I
think for now let's not let's get this
working for quantities let's not cross
the bridge of talking about interval
itself I I personally favor leaving
enter all the way it is many okay mm-hmm
okay wrapped on this point okay
and I think that was what we want to
Jeremy here for and I think that is now
done I think this is why I was here yes
okay okay right thanks field no thanks
all right let's address this one next
I don't so object because this seemed
like a no-brainer I mean it you know the
use case that I had was I've got a whole
giant list of things including all kinds
of exotic nonsense
I just want to know how many of the
following ten things that I can easily
enumerate are in this list patterns are
more questionable I agree with that I
wasn't even thinking about patterns for
this case but so what I'm what i was
thinking of here was so let's say this
for example and then let's say counts
here and what i want to be able to do is
say I just want range of 10 there okay
now okay so the question that it I is
raising is what if those are patterns
some thieves here yeah we could we could
use patterns
I mean patterns would say you know first
you do a cases to find out which occur
and then you run counts I mean this is
equivalent so I claim this particular
thing here arguably is
once two cases of the alternatives of
this followed by running counts we have
count yo it count counts the count if I
say count of line 76 and then I say you
know blank integer but it's gonna say a
hundred right so it's in other words
it's giving a single result what I'm
asking for here what's that yeah yeah I
mean I don't think this gives yeah I
mean that's doing alternatives there so
this is saying make separate counts
because also this wouldn't be so useful
because this is basically you'd have to
go and kind of track down which
corresponds to which right so okay
anybody object to having patterns here
where it's effectively equivalent to the
cases followed by the counts well one
problem you're going to have is that
presumably you want to use the patterns
as the kings of the Association that's
produced no I don't want the patterns
I'd be perfectly happy to have well I
think maybe I haven't thought it through
properly I think I'd be perfectly happy
to have literals that are what the
patterns resolves to resolve you know
what the instances of the patterns in
this particular list are so what I'm
saying is if my pattern so this returns
into account returns and Association
correct so you're telling me that so I'm
saying I'm saying but maybe I'm wrong
here okay so that's what counts normally
does right okay so now the question is
if I were to ask for so let's imagine
here that I were to say you know cases
used you know blank or end blank semi
unless you know n less than 10 then
right
so let's do this let's have that range
okay then the question is and now so one
possible form would be that I'm
effectively saying that so let's imagine
that I used that pattern let's imagine
that the original thing I had was counts
of case
sorry counts of 76 comma and then that
pattern or that pattern in you know
let's say I wanted to have 3 comma 4
comma that pattern so I'm saying
so now the question is is what's
returned the really quite wild as far as
I'm concerned association with that
pattern as one of the keys which seems
to me fairly useless well I don't know
not useless for humans I think it's not
very useful for machines right well so
ok so there are two issues here one is
[Music]
that right so patterns as keys are
essentially wrapped in verbatim so you
can sort of easily extract the count
well I suppose you could but you'd have
to like feed it in the pattern right I
mean I think the other issue is I mean
right that is potentially I guess two
issues one that's potentially a very
long list of things and right if the
patterns aren't necessarily disjoint
that's a good point
oh no it's actually that's a good reason
okay so okay that's a that's a very
interesting case right the patterns that
is not disjoint so is it the case right
now we have the identity for counts that
you know the total of the counts is the
number of elements if we had overlapping
patterns we would break that identity
potentially but if if what we did was to
say you know every pattern gets its
instances
added to its count so that's an argument
against doing it that way and for doing
it in the do the cases first then simply
give the literalized forms of the
patterns mm-hmm I think it's really
pretty useless having patterns as keys
in an association um I don't know other
people have comments Jose anybody else
have comments about this I think that
they count cases Construction is quite
clear well you're you're arguing that we
shouldn't that we just shouldn't do the
thing I'm describing but the problem is
cases the case that's useful is you've
got a list of things and you want to
know how many times do those particular
things occur in a list now obviously you
can apply alternatives and put that into
a cases and break those out and then do
counts but it seems like a sort of a a
no-brainer easy to read code easy to
look for thing that just to say counts
oh you can just count how many times
this list of objects occurs yeah I think
we could have lunch and then use count
itself count does that that's why count
right but what if you ordered but you
have a list if list three four is okay
count in order no no that's not what
you're doing it I listen if you want to
count the ordered pair use count if you
want to count I think what did I is
saying is that if we have annotation
based on lists then we cannot count
objects that are lists but that's not
correct because the look the the the
form is only this form here right so in
the case of okay let's be clear what
we're talking
if I say count you know four five one
two for example and then I say count the
number of instances one two it's gonna
give one right count isn't listable in
any way right I don't know um but um I
don't know the but but now counts plural
this is what I'm proposing is that what
it does is it merely takes object one
object to object three and a list right
so will you two want to count ordered
pairs this is how you would do it see
what I'm saying
and I could perfectly well on this list
just do that and this is not this is
counting at the top level right there's
no ambiguity I think here right so what
would count as just an underscore /semi
in less than ten seconds an arrow
I think perfectly happy for that to be
an error so my impression is that if
these were alternatives they're the most
external list they could be clearer in
general no but why would we do that the
whole point is the whole point is the
use cases you've extracted a list of
things right you want to count how many
times that list of things occurs in this
big data set that's the that's the use
case if you've got alternatives then you
can use cases and you can break it apart
and you can do this and you can say you
know it's different thing that's the use
cases I've got a list of things how many
times do those occur in this and for
example well let's look at letter counts
because I don't remember how that works
um
oh well so let accounts already has
something a bit like this but it's a
slightly weird case because let accounts
is normally counting standard letters
yeah so this is kind of off the off the
reservation for this because it's
already got a restriction to letters um
let's just look at bin counts here yeah
that again works differently I mean you
would have to select right so I think
this is a purely a question for counts I
really like this that I mean this it's
just a lot of use cases that I've had
recently for this particular form if
nobody objects I think we should do this
and we should have it be equivalent to
the cases which splits apart these
things so we're not keying on associate
our own patterns so basically it'll be
pieces list yes except that we didn't
have yes that's correct
yes that is correct yep that's what I'm
proposing okay we don't have objections
I think we should do this let's look at
the next case that I was talking about
which is a merging function for key map
and I know understand why we don't have
that right now where do we have merging
functions we have them for merge right I
I was so it's an option we have an
option merging function in
initialization value initialized and
persistent value but how do we do the
merge for associations when we do I mean
by the way we need another name for join
across this this thing
with with them calling things joins okay
so here oh boy
I think we've actually made these even
more sophisticated now but so this is
this is a slightly different thing but
you understand the issue the issue is
I'm doing a key map and the result of it
so let me give an example okay so let's
imagine that we do well let's do let's
do accounts of random integer we'll do
that same type of thing again
um okay now I say key map now this is
similar to the group by mechanism right
so if I say keymap um hash greater than
fifty forty let's say onto this I'm
gonna get a mess right because what that
did was it picked purely the last
element that happened to you know many
of the things that were false would not
merge they were simply discarded right
now don't we have a don't we have
another place where we're doing this I
mean where we use you get you get what
I'm saying where we're using the fact
that um okay using their combined using
F right so that's where we have two of
these things but I'm saying that that
there is an emergent need for merging so
to speak in key map in fact in general
any of these key star functions could
have that possibility because they
operate on keys I think well which ones
could have that Oh what is the key
collision function what is that
not being joined but nevertheless have
the same key
okay so let's I thought there was
something like this okay no that's a
different thing I don't think so
I mean F of flies producing two
identical right your problem is that
when you keymap f of blah might produce
the same key so you need to choose left
right know what I'm imagining I see what
you're saying well okay that's a but
that's a sequential but that's a new
path well I'm sitting what I'm seeing
here is that key map is very much like
Boop by right because group by is taking
see what I'm saying this is kind of
group by meets key map I think I think
I've seen something similar for sparse
array I'm in telling them exactly where
perhaps a system option for doing what
when you provide rules which have the
same position but different elements
what to do would have to take the mean
to add them etc okay good question
well okay so so what I'm proposing here
is that we have a merging function and
that the merging function will take the
bucket of keys the bucket of outputs
from so okay no no no this is saying
those things which wind up with the same
key how should you combine so for
example I mean again we've had a case
like this where is it we've had we've
had something where we're doing exactly
this where you can say first or list or
whatever actually first wouldn't be the
right thing it will be identity for the
list right so what you're getting what's
fed to the merging function would be the
lists
I'm certain we've had this someplace
else
yeah I'm looking in specially in special
rules we have something called eat of
repeated entries which by default is
first it's a system option okay so it's
not it's not exposed thing but I'm I
remember that we've had this issue I
think this is wait a minute isn't this
the combiner function what is that
called combiner function yes this is
where this comes up what does this even
mean here what does this mean um okay
this is Wow
where on earth does it document that
combiner function arrow JSON works oh
boy
Sushma this is the thing you need to
chase down this is a collection of
examples but but this is a case where we
have something similar right did you get
what the point is here that what what
this is doing is this is saying here's
how
take yeah here's how to take the
fragments right right right right
here's how to take the fragments that
have been created from a template and
combine them together to make the output
this is potentially something that
already happens in association itself
like Association is presented with rules
several rules with the same key right
and it's it's what it does is it throws
out everything except the last one right
okay so what I'm saying is I see you're
saying that Association itself could
have a merging function you know what
this is where I'm remembering this from
this is why I remember it from we talked
about doing that but we didn't have a
good mechanism but what I'm saying is
that this is as basic as a sparse array
and in sparse array there is some system
option that wonders that yes we're not
gonna have a system option it'll be
crazy right the issue is that
Association is a ver args thing that
can't have options as such okay so
normally
you have that list you know if you have
a list that is at the level of this of
an association then what you would
normally say how would you do that so
you have something which is like a list
which has you know a ro 1 b ro 2 a ro 3
cro4 ok the first question is how do you
turn that into an association where a
goes to 1 3 and there is a way to do
that
what is it and if I just say Association
of this it's gonna say as 3 okay
actually that syntax would perfectly
well allow an option here if the first
argument of Association is a list we
could perfectly well have a merging
function there see what I'm saying yeah
that would be quite nice ok so let's see
who
about this in detail who I mean it's
it's constant in and Tom and people like
that know about and tally I guess knows
about the design of Association correct
yeah I was wondering whether me because
these will return on Association but
this could also be useful for a list of
rules returning another list of routes
so perhaps it deserves its own function
well sure um like a key nurse or nurse
geezers no I mean look key map no that's
exact
what this does exactly this is merch
okay for a key value pair mmhmm right so
what this is doing what we're saying is
in key map because it could generate an
association rather than a list which has
you know where you need to insert a
merging operation that isn't the the
pure default Association merging
operation right that's why we need this
option so just to give a sense here of
which other ones here would need that
most of these like key select key sort
key take they don't need that right what
does key Union do yeah so that again
doesn't need it right so it could be
that the only one of these that needs it
is key map because all the others have
the feature that they can never they
just prune an association actually key
sort what is key sort no it just sorts
so again yeah these just sort so they
don't so the only one of these i believe
that needs this is key map and
association itself arguably okay is this
the wrong group of people to figure this
out Sushma can you take that
can we write something up about this and
send it to those other people I think
this is a frankly I think this is a
no-brainer thing to this once we have
merge I think if if it's needed the list
of rules can be made to pass first
through marriage and then Association
well yeah but I don't think we're ever
constructing I'm sure key map is
implemented without going through a list
of rules right
so this is a good thing and I wonder
whether there are other merging
functions that we might need for example
we could put that into sparse array
conceivably okay all right let's just
keep going for a second here what is
Association reap is the associational
version yes the idea here is it's pretty
much the same as sow and reap but the
the kind of syntax of using sow and reap
is a bit ugly at times and so if you can
so in a way that it constructs an
association where the keys are Daniel I
couldn't I don't write yeah yeah this is
Daniel okay
um great Daniel do you have an opinion
about that merging thing were you paying
attention to that that was I was yeah I
mean so it was the conclusion of adding
an option to key map yeah yeah it makes
sense okay all right let's go back to
this sorry I just didn't okay so what is
being proposed here so the issue here is
you know someone will clearly designed
long before associations right it's it's
kind of nice if you can just do so and
reap in a way that you get an
association at the end rather than
having to nest a bunch of reaps because
when you when you use reap typically you
have to take the second part and then
you have to flatten the flat one eye
level and it's just kind of ugly so what
are you proposing here so you just use
you use Association reap and you just
get back an association where the keys
are the kind of keys that were sown and
it's just a bit cleaner code right as
opposed to getting back but wait where
do you get back to the result exactly I
was just reviewing my own thing and
originally I had planned on adding a
special key that would be the the end
result and I ended up in my own code not
worrying about that because I I just had
a set operation inside of the thing that
would capture the result but that is a
good point is there is there a special
key that should be used for the result
or what that's pretty yucky I mean let's
think about that for a second so imagine
so reap let's look at reap for a second
um reap has as a combiner function so
why is C this weird Association yeah so
I also had the I also had the ability to
to so some cases subplots that yeah
Association that's a I didn't end up
using that myself right conceptually I
like it but it might not be practically
useful well the issue is can you so
anything other than a one-dimensional
object mm-hmm you know now arguably okay
so that's big picture of this you know
so is an alternative to assignments for
you know I mean whatever you could do
with so you could now in principle do
with assignments to an association if
I'm not mistaken except that we don't
support that well but I think if if in
the last definition of rib we have F
being rule then this is almost calling
for another argument in which we can put
Association and we replace the list in
the second argument well you could just
wrap Association around the whole thing
and you get it well it's just to avoid
touching the expert there is the result
right but I mean in this case here so
let's take this case here um okay so now
you're saying if I say in the reap here
if I say come a blank comma rule the
heck does that do what did that just do
I think because there's no tag so this
so let's let's imagine that I do is so
um you know floor I over for over three
or something
right so if we have any another head
that replaces the list around the rules
no I understand understands I mean
obviously the case here so what you're
saying is diagonals thing is Association
of lost of this right look it's a
general thing in a bunch of functions
that you know we have returned results
in a list as opposed to in an
association because we didn't have
associations for many years and they're
things where we've got to return three
things and well when we return two
things it's kind of senseless to return
them in the Association but in this case
yeah in this case the question is where
does the result go in the reap what does
this do in the normal case let me just
see
I see so that doesn't have the tags
visible so in order to get the tags
visible you have to put this third
argument is that right Daniel
I haven't used that version of reap but
you could get that I mean that would
allow you so what this is doing is it's
grouping by the tags but it is not
returning the tags and your point is
that returning the tags is useful which
I kind of agree with yes because this is
typically used specifying the tags in
the second argument so you know what you
are going to get back I'm sorry the
second argument the most common thing
would be to specify a tag like two for
example here or at least 0 1 2 3 right
you put that the least right you're
pruning which things you want to get out
right and just specify the order in
which you will get them back I see so
the alternative would be an association
reap the problem is where do you get
where you put the results because I
think it's very bizarre to put the
result I mean you know there's an
association weep in which you'd always
have to say loss of the thing before you
indexed into the you know Association
keys that's also a little funky if if we
are reaping multiple associations don't
we want that to already be a list rather
than an association of associations or
do we really want to have tag goes to I
guess we could do that no sorry what are
you saying in this case here what it
does is it doesn't that the tag is not
used unless you give a third argument
that says how to use the tag so for an
association very flavor of this the tag
would become the key correct okay
I'm still thinking basically that we
could have Association reap return a
list where the first argument the first
thing is the result and after that so
really what this
as hosea has pointed out we can have a
fourth argument to leap which would
achieve the same thing okay there seems
to be no no harm in doing that although
it seems like it's a very ornate object
but have many precedents of function of
staking effigy this is this is like
constructing associations using inner
English right no okay so look I agree
that that's a good thing to put in there
now the question is is there a use for
association leap as a separate so okay
agreed fourth argument here is what to
wrap around the list all right so it's
not an application well or is it an
apply apply I mean the standard thing
with G functions is that they replaced
lists so if G of s comma right and if
you don't want that you say G of list
hash hash type thing right okay okay so
then all right fine that seems
reasonable to me now the question of
whether we need a separate Association
Reap I think we can we can look at once
we have that Reap that form of Reap I'm
not if it wasn't for the fact I can't
imagine making an association Reap have
a different structure with respect to
spending the result as ordinary read and
yet with Association rebuy it doesn't
seem useful unless you can immediately
start indexing into the Association
there's one thing though if we're
returning a bunch of associations and we
use this fourth argument and say it's
Association does that mean that it
applies at both levels no it's just
applying it to the result of I mean what
you'd have to do is you have to say look
the form that you have to do is a little
bit grotesque it's a little bit you know
paint-by-numbers type thing you'd have
to say that you'd have to say rule and
then Association right I mean I don't
know
I you know honestly I'm concerned about
having that fourth argument being apply
as opposed to a construct well I'm just
going to fall away what do we do in many
other cases when we have first effigy
right exactly that's part of them listen
I think we should pick this up next time
I think we're we didn't Tim oh this
beautiful thing oh I wish we'd had a
chance to discuss this I love this
function that's going to be a longer
discussion yes all right okay let's
continue this another day
all right thanks oh thanks for the tips
on the live stream